in the prize episode of words trovo
impossibile perché tu pensi che io
riesca non non va bene
ecco fa vj ragazzi 1 youtuber vero ed è
invece fatta una gambe volta la capacità
faccio con una gamba sola
non ci voglio credere perché ti allacci
le scarpe di questi momenti padre di uk
di merda direi che possiamo cominciare
perché parlo così bella dei ragazzi
benvenuti a questo video sono farisei
oggi siamo tornati su rep
wales hicks luca ma perché dovete usare
ragazzi odio la gente che si mette i
nomi dei pokémon perchè mettete i nomi
dei pokémon sceglietevi un nome vostro
per l'amor di dio un nome bello come
famigerata l'altro è un botto il flip ma
non è ben capito come funziona il botto
fittizio non li devo buttare in una
bocca a caso devo tutta l'iva bekcham
perle cosa come è rimasta in bilico così
no perfetto complimenti zio
io non ho parole ma fate incastrarsi
comunque ragazzi mi sono un po che dato
il pene dei botti facciamo un 100 per
cento impossible che non li abbiamo mai
fatti
andiamo sul sicuro
sto dicendo andiamo sul sicuro facendo
un salto quello più alto ma magari
sicuro proprio no però vabbè chiami
chiara impossi quanti arpione avete
messo casa succedendo
ma cosa era diventato un macaco
paura non ha fatta fa sta roba dini
perfetto bravo sono i lo frate frate dai
frate non mi farebbe perfetto come
staccarsi da un arpione tutorial parte
1669 richiamo al suo livello impossibile
veramente cento per cento imposto perché
non si può fare davvero
a meno che tipo nomi spingano vaffan
perfetto avete mai visto una morte più
stupita di questa no perché io sì ne ho
viste purtroppo ma perché un idolo
scalare ma cosa mi ha fatto dai zio
cherie dai che c'ero secondo me ce la
faccio se continua a far chiudere la
rega impossibile certo livello è
veramente un amico perché comando
l'arpione che problemi c'è questa roba
niente trasferire la mia anima in un
arpione non ha funzionato ragazzi non
sto capendo il si chiamano caio gemina
banana zio mi spieghi che è niente ma
[ __ ] ha perciò non si può fare
ragazzi questo credo sia veramente cento
per cento impulsivo c'è scritto 100 per
cento per un motivo quindi vaffan cuore
passiamo al prossimo daniel veloso e
veloso non veloso che eva è così ragazzi
che si gioca a golf cazzo fatto falsa
cagata affetto e giusto che di quello
stupido e no va bene non ci credo ma non
ci voglio credere [ __ ] devo pure
centrarlo si va mica macello non posso
non posso saltare
va bene io mi stavo già staccando
intentando in qualche modo di buttarla
dentro ma va bene stickman jan fyt
problema non starò e vabbè cos'è sta
roba presto e space su stasis ok a posto
anche regolare porca [ __ ] scusami non
ti posso sperare nel pene o c'è qualche
problema nostro
credo non ti serva più zio ha tanto sto
sparando dei proiettili o bidoni
dell'immondizia sentito rumore fanno
cazzo di rumore per un proiettile
perfetto
l'ue challenge freni o the fuck
no dai vi prego non mi fate fare i salti
e impossibile che salto di merda che
tentativo fallito di fare una cosa è
vera
mi spiace che livello di merda e questo
come faccio a farlo
come ho fatto a falso salto spiegatemi
che roba figlio era bellissimo va bene
edition state hai già suona bene
[Musica]
porca eva questo dovrei aver fatto
malissimo chiusa zio non volevo non
volevo non volevo
beh però mi sono fatto dei nuovi amici
sono bravo a fare queste cose io fare
amicizia
volete essere i miei amici largest
bortolan mica so già che non ce la farò
mai largest sta minchia
e invece va te la cambia volto la gamba
ce la faccio una gamba sola
non ci voglio credere perché ti allacci
le scarpe in questi momenti padre di uk
di merda mi spieghi che problema mentale
hai avuto alla fine del livello prima va
ti sta bene non a luke attento che
dietro c'è né avanti ragazzi aprì a viar
che io a perché adesso hanno fatto anche
l'archivio veramente beh non è questa è
più una pena yorker che io ho però vabbè
ci si accontenta ma frate allora le
arche io dovresti afferrare l'avversario
con le braccia problema che eccola
eccola bene non era esattamente quello
che volevo fare ma mi accontento anche
fossero poteva provare di farla un
attimo meglio vabbè mi chiacchie porta
bruttissima comi casa faccia a prenderlo
con le braccia
esatto bravissimo per questo mi è
piaciuta rock swing dlp productions reit
file tra i five lo vediamo solo se vinco
ok sono già riuscito a fare una roba che
di solito non riesco a fare quindi
perfetto è più appagante della fila alle
poste fare la fila per di rock swing
detto sto giocando veramente a scazzo ma
ce la sto facendo non so come raga non
me lo chiedete like this non dirmi come
fare che faccio rock singh da quando
ancora un è rinato zio
perfetto tesi your lac che come sempre
sarà una merda
no no è a funk bene facciamo che sono
talmente sfortunato che non escono anche
a tirare la palla perfetto devo andare
sul verde ma non mi farei provare ok no
barca [ __ ] questo salvato no zio devi
provare a perfetto perfetto i problemi
ai giovani non avevo dubbi recenti
[ __ ] dr4 dr 04 non so cosa sia ma
sicuramente meglio degli test your life
o un bel calmo che mi sto concentrando
che un gioco dove bisogna usare il
cervello che noi non lo uso spesso io
devo portare la macchina fuori presente
novak e stile 34 minuti dovrei fare
questi livelli ma che 34 giro ma tu sai
con chi stai parlando frate non sono
capace ok ce l'ho fatta ho fatta fermi
perfetto poi giù un [ __ ] no aspetta
c'è qualche problema che forse adesso ci
riesco minchia che professional ma che
39 su 34 mosse ai l'ho fatto in 75 aveva
pharma fotte sega ce n'è un altro già
finito questo per miracolo frate ma sei
scemo questo è decisamente incasinato
dovevo farlo in entro 125 mosse picchia
è più difficile di quanto pensassi
varese non ci fosse questa macchina rosa
di merda ma chi è che la presa paris
hilton a fan cuore dai ce la posso fare
che non ci voglio credere
merda merda merda dai devi toglierti
però ma veramente non ci riesco per
stavo cagata qua seriously fai più
schifo di quanto pensa a eva vetrate non
sono intellettuale sori pro vinto ci ho
messo un'ora ma ho vinto bene fantastico
che cazzo vuoi cosa di insulti che se
non avessi fatto tutto livello cioè le
stime su tre anni ma vera è in realtà e
lo sapevo fare dall'inizio ma ci ho
messo più tempo per sembrare più
interessato a livello non era proprio
una bella scusa
in realtà però va bene in mente una
migliore nel mentre che giochiamo è più
il machete trovo a yeah faccette flop le
può già vinto porca [ __ ]
[Musica]
che gioco di merda perché continua a
giocare è più il sì only for ninja lei
facciamo l'ultimo ragazzi only for e
quello sarebbe un ninja un membro del ku
kux klan
vabbè prima file hard mode non ho capito
però io non ho bisogno la maschera per
vincere
gli olo esatto e come pensavo magari la
maschera mi serve che dite lungo la
maschera la maschera mi fa fare
prestazioni di merda più del solito
hicham perdere ok
porcaccia [ __ ] quanto è difficile
e questa la modalità hard figura ci vole
extreme è ficcata non ho capito quindi
casa extreme
porcaccia [ __ ] dalle middle e middle e
mi da porco demonio ma come fai a darti
uno slancio così pietoso come fai a fare
così schivo steve di merda spiegami che
lancio è quello ma te ma [ __ ] ma
come fa a essere così merdoso ma dalla
vita a questi livelli porcaccia eva tv
disabilità pure vai dritto ma guarda 6
[ __ ]
vai avanti voglio l'ultimo giorno in
altri andrò avanti un ultimo è l'ultimo
mi incazzo è a era già partito grazia di
dio
l'ultimo è quello di andare avanti
[ __ ] di andare avanti [ __ ] o dio
buono che problemi ecco ci mancava solo
che schiacciava come che daremo i pic
the diamond
ah beh allora potevo cliccarlo anche
prima scusa d'accordo anche suoli è
stato alquanto strano fare un livello
del genere ma l'importante e portarsi a
casa il diamante e la patata ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto come se mi è
piaciuto al momento è un mi piace ai
capace di facebook e comitato
trascrizione senso che si rischia di ci
vediamo il prossimo video è la ragazzi